newest daily from science mission
mechanism of brain tumor resistance to
drug is not clearly understood others in
the journal PN ensure that glucose are
acetate to abundant fuel sources in the
brain promote EGFR dependent signaling
through activation of mtor c 2 by
acetylation of its core component
richter mtor see to this forms an auto
activation loop first by promoting
glucose uptake and estelle kuya
production through its dumb stream
pathways of seeming and secondly by
inactivating hdacs which deacetylated
richter and suppresses m2c to buy these
mechanisms where blastoma cells with
activated mtor c2 are resistant to
targeted therapies next kevin was
thought to be a deterrent for coffee
insects that decreased the crop yield by
eighty percent now researchers show that
these insects the great caffeine through
their gut microbes since treatment with
antibiotics detected caffeine in their
system authors isolated several core
microorganisms including prominent
Pseudomonas species from gut microbiota
from seven countries reenact elation of
antibiotic treated insects with an
isolated Pseudomonas train reinstates
caffeine degredation ability confirming
their key role for more news visitors at
ww science mission got form of science
mission facebook page thanks for
watching